today in our school matters series we
look at how educators tackle mental
health in the classroom as we've told
you may is mental health awareness month
advocacy groups say in a given year
nearly one in five adults experience
mental illness this morning Jamie yuccas
shows us how one Northern California
teacher is encouraging students to
reveal their own struggles through a
simple exercise all right I'm gonna
start at the top of page 84 a hundred
Heights it's a good place to start in a
traditional language arts lesson so what
happened we read this part yesterday but
for Aaron Castillo students class work
like this quickly turns into a
discussion on mental health and while
you do that I'm also going to have you
do the check in on the poster for today
the poster Castillo zone creation is a
way for students to share their feelings
a visual representation of how her class
is doing emotionally I already checked
in this morning I actually put my poster
on struggling kids write their name or
initials on the back of a post-it note
and stick it to the board Castillo then
pulls aside any student who puts their
name in one of the bottom categories
something that's really huge is the
stigma around mental health of just
people not feeling comfortable sharing
where they really are and a lot of my
students were like well that's just how
the world is like and that's
heartbreaking to hear was this a driver
your entire life that you wanted to do
something like this to help kids
actually I went here my freshman year
and I witnessed a stabbing my mom could
vouch that I would cry a lot after
school and I just felt like I was kind
of invisible to a lot of my teachers and
part of that was I never talked about it
because I didn't feel comfortable
talking about it cuz no one encouraged
me to talk about it now kids in her
class
save the check-ins and activities like
this sharing circle has helped them open
up about everything from battling
depression to trouble at home when I
came here I wouldn't talk at all how
this class feels like a family cuz like
we could be more comfortable towards
each other once our you know came out
from that dark place and I started to
open up more
more I feel like you know my life has
been so much better sometimes it's those
outside factors of Castillo says these
activities have not only made her class
more empathetic and kind do you like
that idea yeah they've also made them
better students their grades have gone
way up this year their self-esteem has
gone up they're believing in themselves
in analyzing similar social and
emotional learning programs involving
more than 270,000 kids
researchers found their grades improved
by 11 percent now Castillo's message is
going viral after posting the board for
her more than 27,000 Instagram followers
dozens of teachers some as far away as
New Zealand have created their own
versions any kids out there I'm
encouraging you to be like me I'm
encouraging you to talk to your teachers
Castillo hopes these little notes will
continue to make a big difference
Marnie I think giving up that little bit
of time to make sure that we are there
to say to our students I'm here for you
and care about you how can I help you
today there you go good I think this
could be a way to change the world to go
in a new direction and hopefully we get
to a place one day where everyone can
talk about where they're at for CBS this
morning
Jamie yuccas Fremont California there's
a great idea all the different emotions
starting with I'm great I'm in a dark
place John struggling mad day proof and
it's Teacher Appreciation Week so nicely
done